يومكم مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه
المباشره والمستمره للاوضاع في السودان
ففي اليوم التاسع من الاشتباكات استمرت
المواجهات رغم الهدنه المعلنه وتبادل
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الاتهامات
بمهاجمه قافله من الرعايه الفرنسيين ياتي
ذلك فيما تعهدت الخارجيه الفرنسيه باغلاق
سفاراتها في الخرطوم مع انتهاء عمليات
الاجلاء خلال الساعات رغم استمرار الدعوات
الدوليه للتهدئه ووقف دائما لاطلاق النار
تركزت الاشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم
واندرمان وبحري فيما رصد مراسل العربيه
تحليقا للطيران الحربي في مدن سودانيه عده
وفي ابرز التطورات الميدانيه تتواصل
الاشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع حيث شهدت بعض احياء
بحري وام درمان والخرطوم تحليقا للطيران
الحربي بحسب شهود عيان من جهه اخرى اتهمت
قوات الدعم السريع طيران الجيش بقصف
مواقعها في منطقه كارفور بالخرطوم بحري
فيما تواصل انقطاع خدمه المياه في مدينه
بحر وعدد من احياء ولايه الخرطوم هذا ومن
المقرر ان تنتهي مساء اليوم هدنه كان وافق
عليها الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بينما
تواصلت حركه النزوح من الخرطوم الى
الولايات السودانيه الاخرى
هذا والتقطت كاميرا العربيه مشاهد للوضع
الانساني من داخل المستشفى الدولي في
السودان وهو المستشفى الوحيد الذي يعمل في
مدينه بحري ويعاني عجزا في الكوادر الطبيه
واصابات عده بحسب احد الاطباء المتطوعين
هناك
تحت الحر وعملنا عمليه كبيره في مستشفى
الدول
الجديده من المستشفى
الدولي لانه فعليا
اكبر مني ان احنا
في حاله ثانيه هناك
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنه تبادل الطرفان
لتهامات بشان الاعتداء على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه بينما تستمر عمليه الاجلاء
للرعايه الاجانب حيث اتهم الجيش السوداني
قوات دعم السريع بارتكاب انتهاكات ضد
بعثات دبلوماسيه ليله امس وذكر الجيش
السوداني في بيان ان عناصر من الدعم
السريع اعتدت على السفير الماليزي والبعث
القطري المتجهه الى بورتسودان كما تعرض
موكب السفاره الفرنسيه لاطلاق نار ما ادى
الى عودتهم وتعطيل عمليه الاجلاء في
المقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان
ان طائرات الجيش هي التي استهدفت موكب
السفاره الفرنسيه وشدد الدعم السريع على
التزامها بالهدنه وتسهيل حركه الرعايه
الاجانب لمناطق الاجلاء
من جانبي تعمل مستشار الاول لقائد قوات
الدعم السريع فارس النور تهم في مقابله مع
العربيه عناصر قال انها مندسه واتهمهم
بتنفيذ الاعتداءات على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
هنالك الان
كتيبه كامله متفرغه من الطرف الاخر ترتدي
زي الدعم السريع لكي تدق السينما بين
الدعم السريع والمجتمع الدولي هم انضربوا
الرصاص على السيارات السفاره الامريكيه هم
اعتدوا على
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي
ونفى النور للعربيه رغبه الدعم السريع
كبديلا عن الجيش وقال ان قوات الدعم
السريع مستعده للدماج في الجيش بعد تطهيره
من عصابات سيطرت عليه وفق تعبيره ان الجيش
السوداني الان مختطف وابناء الشعب
السوداني وهنا في نقطه مهمه حتى
يعني احنا ما صارحين نفسنا بديل للجيش
السوداني
[موسيقى]
الجيش السوداني من العصابه التي سيطرت
عليه وبعد ذلك الجيش السوداني هو الاساس
لكي نكون جيش قومي نحن سوف نندمج في الجيش
السوداني لكي نكون جيش رومي يحمي الدستور
يحمل البلاد من الاعداء الخارجيين
هذا هدفنا نحن لسنا بديلين للجيش
هذا واعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان ارتفاع
عدد ضحايا الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع الى 264 قتيلا من المدنيين
و1543 جريحا اوضحت اللجنه في بيان ان هناك
الكثير من الاصابات والوفيات غير مشموله
في هذا الحصر حيث لم تتمكن من الوصول الى
المستشفيات لصعوبه التنقل والوضع الامني
في البلاد
هذا وافاد موقع رص للانترنت ان السودان
يعاني انقطاعا شبه كامل لخدمه الانترنت مع
دخول المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وبين
قوات الدعم السريع اسبوع الثاني وقالت
منظمه نت بلوكس ومقرها لندن قالت ان
بيانات الشبكه تظهر انهيارا شبه كامل
لاتصال بالانترنت حيث تبلغ نسبه الاتصال
حاليا 2% مقارنه بالمستويات العاديه
ومستمرون معكم اذا في هذه التغطيه طوال
اليوم الاول منذ اندلاع الشبكات في الخامس
عشر من ابريل ونذهب معكم ايضا الى ضيوف
العربيه الكرام ما نذهب الى الخرطوم ومعنا
من هناك الصحه والمحلل السياسي يوسف سراج
الدين اهلا بك سيد يوسف معنا في سياق هذه
التغطيه على العربيه ساعات تفصلنا على
انتهاء الهدنه المعلنه والتي وصفت بالهشه
حتى هذه اللحظه ماذا نتوقع وفق المعطيات
على الارض الان
[موسيقى]
المزيد من
الانفجار مزيد من الاستدامه المعارك بعد
اجل المعلنه اصلا في الفتره الماضيه ثلاثه
ايام وهذا سيف بطبيعه الحال من الازمات
الكبيره والصاحنه الان التي يمكن على كاهل
المواطن البسيط الذي فات الان لا يقوى على
الاستمرار في حاله التخلق في المنايا
المتابع للتصريحات اليوم وخصوصا على لسان
القاده وعلى لسان الرجلين الاساسيين نتحدث
على البرهان وحمتي كان واضح الكلام
تصريحات ناريه انا او لا احد غيري كل طرف
يريد اقصاء الطرف الاخر توجيهه للعداله
ومحاكمته ومستعد للقتال حتى اخر رمق
بالتالي هل يمكن الحديث عن مسبب اليوم ما
الذي يمكن ان يطيل امد الحرب او هذه
المعركه في السودان
انا اعتقد انه الخطافات التي
لقائدي او لقائد الدعم السريع للجهه
المسلحه او رئيس مجلس السياده
تشير الى انه هنالك
شافع جدا في بينهما والكل يمضي باتجاه ما
يمضي فيه ولكن
في طبيعه الحروف ان تتوقع دائما وابدا
خطابات قد لا تقلوا احيانا من المقابره قد
لا تقلوا احيانا من التاك في العسكري ايضا
ينسحب حتى اعرف تصريحات يعني نحن ندمر
ابدا في الاعلام يعني ننتظر حقيقه مطلقه
من اي طرف الشك يظن قائما في كثير من
المواضيع حتى يستفيد الشاهد ان الان هنالك
تضارب كبير جدا في المعلومات بشان الاوضاع
على الارض
تؤكد او
تعلن دوما وابدا انها تهيمن وتسيطر
وبالتالي هنالك من يمشي بالجهه الاخرى هذه
السيطره وما الى ذلك يعني لكن انا اعترف
المعارك في
بات الصديق المساحات المناوره بين الاطراف
كلها الان
الصحه على ان هناك اوضاع كثيره هنالك
مواطنين مواطنين العاصمه المثلثه واسماء
مغادرتهم
مغادره المواطنين يا استاذ يوسف وايضا
يعني عندما نتحدث عن بعثات دبلوماسيه بدات
تجلي رعاياها يوم امس ايضا دول بدات
باجراء رعاياها وانتهت عمليات الاجلاء
ماذا يعني ذلك هل يعني بان هناك ربما
معركه كسر عظم قادمه في المستقبل القريب
اتمنى نتحدث عن دول ودول الكبرى بدات ان
تجلي كل رعاياها واتممت العمليه اليوم
فرنسا ايضا انضمت الى ركب الدول التي تجري
رعاياها
صحيح هو انه هذه العمليات كان لها وقعي
واثر على المواطن السوداني الذي يستعصم
بمنزله الذي ينتظره ويرج هذه الازمه ولكن
بينما هو يرى ويسمع عن بلاد رعايه دول
بعينها بهذه
الكبريات الدول تقريبا الان بدات ان لم
تجري فعليا هذا يعكس جانب ان هنالك
اشياء في الافق وتم الامور ستحدث فبالتالي
هذا يضاعف من القلق الموجود اصلا لدى كثير
من المواطنين ويرشح عندهم بانها ستكون
اصعب خصوصا وتاتي بعد نحن ندخل في الاسبوع
الثاني
للحرب
عن الرعايه وعمليات الاجلاء ايضا الان
ايطاليا كما تتابعون في هذا العاجل اسفل
الشاشه امامكم ايطاليا تعلن اجلاء 19 من
رعاياها في السودان بالتنسيق مع مصر اذا
ايطاليا ايضا لا تعلن اجلاء تسعه عشر من
رعايه في السودان بالتنسيق مع مصر وكانت
الخارجيه الفرنسيه اليوم اعلنت عن اجلاء
وبدء عمليه الاجلاء في السودان خصوصا من
قبل الرعايه اليوم حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتضح
الامور سنعرف من مراسلنا على كل حال عن من
الذين ستشملهم عمليه الاجلاء خصوصا وانا
عمليه الاجلاء الامريكيه كانت شملت من
الهيئات الدبلوماسيه هل ستكون ربما عمليه
الاجلاء من قبل الفرنسيين لمواطنين
فرنسيين مقيمين في السودان وما هي
الجنسيات الاخرى الذين ايضا ستشملهم عمليه
الاجلاء هذه كل هذه التفاصيل سنعرفها في
سياق هذه التغطيه بالتنسيق مع مراسلي وم
مكاتب العربيه حول العالم على كل حال ايضا
ايطاليا تنضم الى ركب الدول التي تعلن عن
اجلاء رعاياها وستبدا في عمليه الاجلاء في
غضون ايضا الساعات والايام المقبله وسط
تصاعد حده الاشتباكات ومطالبه دوليه
وعربيه ايضا باقل توفير ممرات امنه
للمواطنين وايضا عدم التعرض لعمليات
الاجلاء من قبل للرعايه ايضا من قبل
الاطراف المتحاربه اعود اليك سيد يوسف
سراج الدين حقيقه يعني الوضع في السودان
يحتمل الكثير والكثير من التساؤلات اليوم
اريد ايضا ان اعرف استاذ يوسف كما بدات
تتحدث الكثير من المواقع عن امكانيه
واحتمال خروج الناس الى الشارع هل الامور
المعطيات على الارض توحي بان الناس فعلا
سيخرجون يرفعون رايات بيضاء يت ظاهرون ضد
كل القوى العسكريه المتحاربه اليوم في
السودان
الحل هذا الامر موجود ولكنه موجود مستتر
في نفوس الناس الذين يقبعون الان في
منازلهم وغير راضيين عن هذه الحرف التي
القائد الاعلى القوات المسلحه لانها عبديه
ناهيك عن المواطن الذي يستوي لنيرانها هذه
عمليه الربط يعني اعتقد انها هي عمليه
موجوده ضررنا نتابع حتى في البيانات
المختلفه لجان المقاومه الشبابيه هي
العمود الفقري للثوره المدينه هي من
الثوره واستطاعت
نظام
11 ابريل 2019 كما هو معلوم
منذ ذلك التاريخ جذوره الثوره السودانيه
لم تخلوا شوارعها طيله الفترات السابقه
هي مهمه جدا وترتبط ارتباط وسيم بهذه
الحرب التي تدور الان بدءا من اعتقد ان
المحطاتها في ان هنالك
طيب استاذ يوسف يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال مع
استاذ يوسف سراج الدين الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي سنعود اليه في حال توفر في سياق
هذه التغطيه عبر العربيه طبعا ونحن نحدثكم
نعرض دائما الصور مباشره عبر شاشه العربي
وحتى الفيديوهات التي وصلتنا وتصلنا منها
خاص للعربيه ان نتابع معكم هذه الشاشه
مقسمه الى اربع اجزاء طبعا في يمين الشاشه
من الاعلى اول ظهور لحمتي وكنا نقلنا
ونشرنا لكم هذا الفيديو لقائد قوات الدعم
السريع وسط التساؤلات التي كانت تحيط
بالرجلين اين هما منذ اليوم الاول لاندلاع
حده الاشتباكات بين الطرفين هذا الفيديو
لما يقال بانه امام القصر الجمهوري كان
حميتي مع قوات الدعم السريعه على عربه
عسكريه مع بعض القوات
وكانها هي اشاره بانه موجود هو ليس مختبئ
كما تقول مثلا الروايه من الجيش في
الاتمات متبادله بين الاطراف كافه والكل
يسال اين الاخر لماذا هو مختبئ لانه حتى
هذه الساعه وهذا اليوم كنا فقط نسمع اصوات
الرجلين عبر مقابلات تلفزيونيه ولم يتم
ايضا الكشف على المكانيمها بالصوت والصوره
ليس فقط في الصوت الان ايضا على يسار
الشاشه نتابع لفيديوهات وصور لعمليات نزوح
واسعه جراء لاشتباكات وايضا لعمليات
الاجلاء في اسفل الشاشه التي كانت بدات
منذ يوم امس وكانت السعوديه تراست عمليه
اجلاء 91 من المواطنين السعوديين الى جانب
ايضا من جنسيات اخرى ومن بعض الدول
العربيه الشقيقه والمجاوره للسعوديه على
كل حال ايضا ايطاليا اعلنت اجراء البدء
باعلان 19 من رعايه هو ايضا بالنسبه
لفرنسا اليوم وامريكا في صباح هذا اليوم
نذهب الى هذه الاخبار ومع الاضطرابات في
السودان اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه
اصابه احد اعضاء السفاره في الخرطوم بطلق
النار اكدت ان هذا الحادث يؤكد مره اخرى
على ضروره توخي اقصى درجات الحذر حفاظا
على سلامه المواطنين ودبلوماسيين وضعت
الخارجيه المصريه دعت المواطنين المصريين
الموجودين خارج الخرطوم الى التوجه الى
مدينتي حلفا وبورتسودان تمهيدا لاجلائهم
هذا وقالت مصادر العربيه ان مصر ستمنح
تاشيره دخول الرعايه الاجانب القادمين من
السودان
نذهب اذا الى القاهره ومعنى من هناك مديره
مكتب العربيه في مصر رنده ابو العزم رنده
مرحبا بك معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه اليوم
بيان مهمان جاء من مصر نريد ان نعرف
تفاصيلهما وحيثيتهما فيما يتعلق بمساله
الرعايه الموجودين في السودان
نعم نادين بالفعل كما ذكرتي هناك بينان
صدر الواحد تلو الاخر وهذا كان يعني عقب
بيان صدر اول امس من الخارجيه المصريه عن
التنسيق
لاجلاء او الخروج الرعايه المصريين عبر
المنافذ كان ولكن اليوم ما ذكره المتحدث
الرسمي السفير احمد ابو زيد ان السفاره
المصريه تعمل ولا يتم اغلاقها لان عدد
الرعايه المصريين الموجودين بالخرطوم على
الاقل من عشره الاف مصري اذا الرعايه
الاجانب اعدادهم بتقوم بالعشرات ولكن او
حتى بالمئات ولكن كبر العدد يجعل يعني
هناك صعوبه كبيره في اجلائهم وبالتالي
لابد من وجود سفاره مصريه تعمل او قنصليه
المصريه ستعمل كما هي برغم اصابه احد
افراد
البعثه الدبلوماسيه المصريه بطلق الناري
السفير ايضا احمد ابو زيد لم يوجه الاتهام
لا احد رفيع النزاع وقال ان هذا مجال
تحقيق اما بالنسبه لخروج الرعايه هو كما
ذكر في البيان ان الخرطوم بتبعد عن وادي
حلفا او عن الميناء البري قصه الاشكيت نحو
900 كلم تبعد عن طول سودان نحو 675 كلم
هذه طرق غير مؤمنه ولهذا ناشد المصريين
الموجودين في هذه الاماكن بالت في الخرطوم
بالتزام منازلهم لحتى وجود تامين لهم خروج
حاولنا اليوم الاتصال ببعض الطلبه
المتواجدين داخل الخرطوم والذين عرفنا او
علمنا من ذويهم هنا في مصر بانهم حاولوا
المغادره الهواتف كانت مغلقه وهم في
طريقين الى احد المنافق البريه عبر باصات
خاصه ايضا علمنا ان الاسعار استضاعفت
بصوره كبيره جدا
الحافله التي كانت تقلهم كانت يعني قبل
الحرب 30 دولار الان اصبحت ب 300 دولار
ولكن الطرق غير مؤمنه كما نرى وكما نعلم
جميعا يعني وفق المعلومات
نعم بحسب المصادر للعربيه انه سيتم
الاجلاء من خلال البحر والجو وستصل ايضا
بحسب المصادر نادين طائرات مصريه الى بور
سودان وسفن مصريه يعني سيكون هناك اجلاء
بكل الوسائل التحركات نظرا
لعدم التامين ستكون بحذر شديد وسريه ايضا
عمليات الاجلاء متوقفه على ايجاد ممرات
امنه وعدم استهداف تلك الممرات ذكر او
ذكرتي قبل قليل ان ايطاليا بتنسق في خروج
19 من رعاياها من نعلم ايضا من المصادر ان
نعم ان هناك تنسيق مصري ايضا يوناني قبرصي
بشان اجلاء رعايه واتفاق على فتح خط اتصال
مباشر لاجراء رعايه تابعين للدول الثلاث
اضافه الى دول اخرى كانت قد طلبت من مصر
منذ عده ايام في اتصالات مع وزير الخارجيه
المصريه من بينها هولندا للتواصل ايضا او
المساعده في خروج رعاياهم اذا اضافه الى
ذكرتموه من ايطاليا هناك قبرص واليونان
عمليات الاجلاء المصريه ستتم على عده
مراحل مختلفه وبحسب المصادر ستتم ايضا في
توقيتات زمنيه مختلفه ما تم الاتفاق عليه
هو اعطاء اشاره البدء في عمليه الاجلاء
وتامين هذه العمليات من كافه اجهزه الدوله
يتم التشاور الان في مصر حول عدد الرحلات
اليوميه الى بورسودان البدايه سيكون هناك
سيارتين بشكل يومي سيتحدى ذلك على خلفيه
الاشتباكات
ووجود هدنه او وجود تامين لان تهبط هذه
الطائرات في السودان في اي من المطارات
التي ستكون مؤمنه الموعد النهائي لعمليات
الاجلاء بيتوقف على وصول مصريين لن
الاجلاء دون اي مشاكل هناك ايضا بحسب
المصادر للعربيه نادين هناك تخوف من دخول
عناصر ارهابيه من جماعه الاخوان التي كانت
قد هربت من مصر عام 2013 ان تحاول الدخول
مره اخرى الى مصر عبر احد المنافس خصوصا
المنفذ البري
باستخدامه هويات مدوره وايضا من فصول اي
تدافع هناك اذا علمنا ايضا ان هناك اكثر
من اربعه ملايين سوداني داخل مصر الان
ربما بعض الاسر ستحاول لم الشمل والدخول
بحسب ما تواصلت مع بعض الجهاز وذكروا انه
من يثبت يعني اوراقه وانه سليمه سيتمكن من
الدخول ولكن هناك عمليه تدقيق شديده جدا
على المعابر والمنافذ لمنع دخول اي عمليات
او اي ارهابيين وايضا لضمان عدم تدافع او
وجود الاجتياح لهذه المنافذ تفضل الحقيقه
العديد من النقاط المهمه التي اشرت اليها
وفقا لمصادر العربيه وتتحدث اليوم عن
الدور المصري وهذا التنسيق اليوناني
المصري القبرصي لاجلاء الرعايه وايضا
توفير ممرات امنه في نقطه اخيره رنده اريد
التركيز عليها تحدثت عن تخوف من دخول
عناصر ارهابيه ان تحاول دخول مره اخرى عبر
المنفذ البري اليوم الى جانب هذه المخاوف
من دخول العناصر الارهابيه هناك عدد كبير
من السودانيين ربما يريدون ان يمروا الى
مصر عبر الحدود البريه هربا من الوضع
القائم كيف يتم اذا التنسيق اجراء عمليه
دخوله هؤلاء خصوصا من المدنيين المواطنين
الهاربين من هذه المع نعم هذه نقطه مهمه
جدا لان كما ذكرت لك ان هناك اربعه ملايين
سوداني لا اسر يعني او امتداد الاسر
وهؤلاء سيحاول ولم الشمل او الدخول الى
مصر
من سيثبت او سيستطيع اثبات انه له الاحقيه
في الدخول ربما سيدخل ولكن تعلمين ان
الوضع الاقتصادي في مصر ووضع صعب حاليا
مصر بتعامل الجميع كانهم مواطنين مصريين
ولا تعاملهم كلاجئين اطلاقا سواء الاخوه
او الاشقاء من السودان من سوريا من اليمن
ولكن هذا سيضع عبء اقتصادي جديد على مصر
في حال دخول ملايين من السودانيين الى مصر
ولكن حتى الان لا يوجد منع بحسب ما علمت
ولكن من سيثبت احقيته في الدخول سيتمكن من
الدخول نعم طيب راندا مصر دائما هي سباقه
وعرابه الهدن والوسطات خصوصا في الازمات
الشائكه في منطقتنا العربيه اليوم هل يمكن
حدوث الحديث عن جهود مصريه يمكن اخذ بعين
الاعتبار لربما تقريب وجهات النظر بين
الطرفين او اقل الوصول الى هدنه طويله
الامد
نعم هذه جهود لن تتوقف منذ بدايه الازمه
وشاهدنا معا ان كان هناك مبادره او نداء
او مبادره من الرئيس السيسي مع رئيس جنوب
السودان
لوجود هدنه وايقاف اطلاق النيران وهذا
ايضا تم التواصل في بين وزير الخارجيه
المصريه وعدد من الدول الاوروبيه وايضا
بين الرئيس السيسي والامين العام للامم
المتحده نداء وجهه امين عام الجامعه
العربيه كلها لايقاف اطلاق النيران لان ما
يحدث الان في خطوره كبيره جدا من اندلاع
حرب اهليه يمكن ان تؤثر تعلمين ان ان
السودان هو عمق استراتيجي وهو الامن
القومي لمصر مثله مثل ليبيا اي احداث فيها
اضطرابات تحدث في السودان ستنعكس الى اعلى
مصر وبالتالي يعني ليس فقط المسائل
المصريه ليس فقط لانها دوله شقيقه لكن
لانها في البدايه هي عمق استراتيجي لمصر
التوصل الى ايقاف اطلاق النيران هو الامر
الملح الان ليس فقط انسانيا ولكن لتامين
خروج رعايه لتامين اصول مساعدات غذائيه
لتامين يعني هذا امر ملح ولكن هذا يتوقف
على طرفي النزاع الذي كما نرى لا يعني
يتواصلوا لا لا يوقفوا او لا يحترموا اي
هدنه حتى هذه اللحظه نحن نشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه المعلومات وتفاصيل من القاهره
مديره مكتب العربيه في مصر رنده ابو العزم
وعلى صعيد عمليات الاجلاء المستمره في
السودان اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن
بدء عمليه اجلاء سريعه لمواطنيها ولطاقمها
دبلوماسي بعد ان دخلت المعارك العنيفه
اسبوعها الثاني ولفتت الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الى ان العمليه ستشمل ايضا مواطنين
اوروبيين واخرين يتبعون دولا حليفه مؤكده
انها حصلت على ضمانات من طرفي الصراع في
السودان لتامين عمليه الاجلاء
والاطلاع على تفاصيل عمليه الاجلاء
الفرنسيه معنا من باريس حسين قنيبر مكتب
العربيه في فرنسا حسين مرحبا بك معنا في
سياق هذه التغطيه على العربيه من هم الذين
ستشملهم عمليه الاجلاء الفرنسيه اولا
اهلا بك نادين في الواقع البيان الذي صدر
عن وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه اوضح انه
بالتنسيق مع وزاره الدفاع ستكون هناك
عمليه اجلاء سريعه لرعايانا وطواقم
بعثاتنا الدبلوماسيه في السودان بالتنسيق
مع كل الاطراف المعنيه وتشمل عمليه
الاجلاء مواطنين الفرنسيين مقيمين في
السودان وايضا افراد البعثات الدبلوماسيه
الفرنسيه في هذا البلد ولكن
الجديده هو ان الناطقه باسم الخارجيه انت
اوضحت بعد صدور البيان ان عمليه الاجلاء
يجب ان تؤدي في النهايه الى اغلاق سفاره
فرنسا في الخرطوم هدفنا ان تحصل العمليه
في اسرع وقت ممكن واشارت لجوند ايضا الى
ان بعض
الفرنسيين في السودان لا يرغبون في
المغادره اما لان لديهم روابط عائليه او
لاسباب اخرى طبعا الذين لديهم روابط
عائليه هم الفرنسيون من اصل سوداني وهؤلاء
التواصل الخليه الازمه الاتصال بهم يوميا
اذا اصروا على البقاء في السودان وهم
اقليه في كل الاحوال هؤلاء الذين يرفضون
المغادره نعم طيب حسين اذا بالحديث عن كل
تفاصيل عمليه الاجلاء الاجلاء هذه هل من
خطوات ضمانات تم اتخاذها للحصول على عمليه
اجلاء امنه فرنسيه
تماما بيان الخارجيه الفرنسيه اوضح ان
الطرفي النزاع في السودان اي الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع القدمه ضمانات الامنيه
تسمح بهذه العمليه بعمليات فقط اسمح لي
على المقاطعه نحن نتابع معكم هذه الصور
والمشاهد التي وصلتنا ننقلها لكم لعمليات
نزوح من الخرطوم مع استمرار الاشتباكات
اذا عدد كبير من الباصات الواحد تلو الاخر
الان هي باتجاه ولايات اخرى الخرطوم
العاصمه السودانيه اصبح الوضع فيها خطر
للغايه كما يقول المواطنون السودانيون لم
تعد منطقه امنه هناك في السودان في
الخرطوم بالتحديد العاصمه السودانيه مطرا
الناس للزحف نحو الولايات الاخرى
والابتعاد عن العاصمه العاصمه السودانيه
اليوم بلا ماء بلا كهرباء بلا وقود هذا
كله يضاف الى الازمه الاقتصاديه التي كانت
اصلا موجوده خصوصا بعد ثوره عام 1900 2019
بعد الاطاحه بنظام البشير ومن بعدها توالت
الازمات وتعقدت الامور لحين الوصول كان
الى بقعه امل في الضوء وخصوصا فيما يتعلق
بتوقيع الاتفاق الاطاري ومن ثم حدث ما حدث
واندلعت الاشتباكات بين الطرفين العسكريين
في السودان ولكن دائما المواطن هو من يدفع
الثمن المواطن اليوم السوداني يعيش حاله
من الخوف وحاله من الذعر هذه السيارات
وهذه الباصات خير دليل على ما يحصل في
السودان اليوم الناس تذهب بالمئات
وبالعشرات يعني تشاد تقول بان وصلها عشرين
الف سوداني منذ ان بدات الاحتجاجات اليوم
هذه الصور نوضح لكم لعمليات النزوح الى
ولايات اقل خطرا والى مدن اقل خطرا ولا
توجد فيها هذه الاشتباكات وحجم الماساه
اليوم طبعا هذا الصراع ياخذ ابعادا عده من
انه صراع بدا بين طرفين عسكريين متحاربين
الى
سيناريوهات متوقع ان تكون اكثر تصعيدا
تذهب بها البلاد الى حرب اهليه واندلاع
مظاهرات من قبل الشارع وطبعا كلا يتمنى كل
هذه السيناريوه لكنها باتت متوقعه في ظل
وضع وبعد استراتيجي له السودان الموجوده
اصلا على حدود هي تتجاور سبع دول اصلا
مضطربه في منطقه اصلا حساسه الوضع اصلا
متاذن سواء في السودان او حتى في حدودها
فبالتالي هناك تخوفات ايضا من اندلاع ايضا
اشتباكات قبليه طبعا هذه الصور التي
نتابعها الان هي تظهر حجم الاشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع نستمع
الى صوت الطبيعي
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
المدنيون مهددون معرضون بشكل مباشر جراءه
الاشتباكات المستمره بين طرفي النزاع
العسكريين هذا الفيديو وثقه مواطن سوداني
من منزله ومن بيته وتظهر ايضا وتسمع طلقات
الناريه تصنع الاصوات وهذه تشققات
الموجوده حيث ان اسقف المنازل للسودانيين
بدات تسقط على رؤوس قاتنيها ايضا اصبحوا
يعيشون بخوف وذعر
بمدنهم وخصوصا العاصمه السودانيه اصبحت
تفتقر لابسط مقومات الحياه لكي يعيشوا وسط
هذا الطقس
الحار اليوم وايضا وسط نقص كل مكونات
الحياه نتحدث عن مياه ونتحدث عن وقود
وايضا كهرباء اليوم نستمع مجددا ونعرض لكم
هذه الفيديوهات التي تصلنا لتبادل اطلاق
نار وحتى استمرار الاشتباكات التي ما زالت
مستمره حتى اللحظه في العاصمه السودانيه
وبعد الولايات الاخرى في السودان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا دائما التغطيه مستمره على العربيه
وننقل لكم بالصوت والصوره والفيديوهات
تريدون لحظه بلحظه لمجريات الاحداث التي
تحصل في السودان ونذهب مره اخرى الان الى
الخرطوم بحري ينضم الينا من هناك صحفي
عمار ابو شيبه عمار مرحبا بك معنا في سياق
هذه التغطيه نحن نعرض الان على شاشه
العربيه ضمن هذه التغطيه المباشره فيديو
متداول لتداول تبادل اطلاق نار واستمرار
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم حتى هذه اللحظه ما
زال صوت السلاح هو الصوت الوحيد في المدن
السودانيه وخصوصا في العاصمه الخرطوم ماذا
يعني ذلك على اي سيناريو نتوقع ما هي
الترجيحات وفقا
للوضع على الارض حيث انتم
نعم يعني بحسب ما تابعنا ونشاهد من هذه
الاشتباكات العسكريه وبين القوتين يعني
على ذكر المثال بالامس الاشتباكات التي
جرت في مدينه الخرطوم البحري ونتيجه ايضا
في عدد مناطق بشكل واضح
قوات المساء التي نشرت على ارض المعركه
الان هي تحاول ان تحدث اختراق ما بين هذه
القوات المتعصره عدد
ربما يذهب بنا الى ان العمليات ربما تطول
حتى يتم يعني عمليات اختراق اكثر بحسب
بيان الجيش ذكر بانها المرحله الثانيه هي
مرحله التبشيط وبحسب بيانات الدعم السريع
يتتحدث عن انها تستطيع الحركه وتستطيع ان
تسيطر على عدد من المواقع
المشاهده بشكل لاستخدام سلاح الطيران حتى
الان تحدثنا عن سلاح الطيران عمار نحن
ايضا نعرض للمشاهدين هذه المشاهد لتحقيق
طيران حربي للجيش السوداني في العاصمه
السودانيه نتابع معكم هذه الصور وانت
تحدثنا تفضل عمار اكمل فكرتك حول
المعلومات لو سمحت
يعني الملاحظه استخدام جناح الطيران الان
في هذه المعركه ربما هو الاجناب فرقه
المشاعر والارض التي تم نشرها بشكل واضح
وهذه الثقه المعروفه خير ما تنتشر تحتاج
الى
وتحتاج الى قوات اسناد وتحتاج الى عمليات
نوعيه على ارض الواقع حتى تؤدي المهام
قوات الدعم تتحدث ايضا بعدها قاده عدد من
المعارك في عدد من المناطق الخاصه على
مستوى مدينه البحري ومحيط القصر الرئاسي
المناطق الاستراتيجيه
هذا السيناريو يعني وهذه النقاط ربما تشير
لان المعارك قد تمتد الى فتره طويله وهذا
ما جعل عدد من البعثات الدوليه ان تدري
رعاياها من العاصمه الخرطوم صعوبه الوضع
فيها اليوم
هذه السيناريوهات مرجحه وتحتمل نظريات عده
لكن اليوم يعني نريد ان نفهم الوضع
السودان مر عليه العديد من الازمات العديد
من الويلات والحروب والصراعات والقبليه
منها لكن عندما تصل هذه الازمه الى
العاصمه السودانيه هناك قلق هناك ريبه
وهناك خوف شديدين ماذا ننتظر ماذا نتوقع
عندما تصل الحروب والصراعات الى وسط وقلب
العاصمه السودانيه ماذا يعني ذلك
نعم ربما النظره العسكريه تكون مختلفه جدا
باعتبار ان العقيده العسكريه مدربه وتظهر
بطبيعه الصراع العسكريه هو هذه الصراعات
هي ليست غريبه على الجانب العسكري اما
بالجانب المدنيين فهذه الصراعات هي غريبه
على مواطنين لم يشهدوا هذه الصراعات او
يعني على تاريخ السودان وتاريخ العاصمه
وكانت هنالك كثير جدا من الاشتباكات
العسكريه في العاصمه لكن لم تدم بهذا يعني
هذا المقدار وربما كانت هذه اطول عمليه
عسكريه داخل العاصمه
منذ الان 25 تمرد الكتيبه السودانيه في
الجيش الاحتلال البريطاني ومن ثم يعني
عمليات الانقلابات العسكريه التي جرت حكما
لليره وحكم السيد
الرئيس المخلوع وعديد من المراحل التي مرت
بها وحتى عمليه الزراعه الطويل لجبريل
ابراهيم الذي كانت قبل عده سنوات
العاصمه الصراعات الحربيه لكن هذه العمليه
تعد هي اطول خاصه وانها في وسط العاص بعدد
من الاحياء وهنالك قوات ترتكز وتسيطر على
مقر استراتيجيه وتضم بيانات حقا لداخل
الاذاعه السودانيه وانها ما زالت مسيطره
وبالجانب الاخر يعني المدنيه الان اصبحت
خياراتهم بسيطه جدا في عمليه
الاستمرار داخل العاصمه
للمواطنين فقط ايضا لنفهم ونقرب الصوره
ماذا يجري بالتحديد على الارض عمار اي
المراكز المنشات المناطق التي تتركز فيها
حده الاشتباكات اكثر من غيرها في العاصمه
السودانيه
يعني بحسب الوارد وبحسب ما كان عليه يبدو
الوضع في وسط الخرطوم كما هو مع انحسار
العدد من
القوات او الاشتباكات
يعني محيط القياده العامه للجيش ومحيط
مطار الخرطوم هما ما زالت فيهما السيطره
والاشتباكات العسكريه واضحه السيده
البرهان ذكر بالامس بان
مطار الخرطوم ومطار خارج السيطره للقوات
المسلحه في قماش كالات وهذه تعني النقود
الدعم السريع ما زالت مستمره في هذه
المنطقه منطقه القصر الجمهوري ايضا ما
زالت قوات الدعم الشريف تحصل فيها وهنالك
في وسط الخرطوم عدد من المناطق
الاستراتيجيه والمنطقه جنوب الخرطوم ايضا
كذلك المنطقه البحري تشهد سيطره من الدعم
السريع في المناطق الجيش ايضا كذلك بشر
عدد من فرقه المشافي عدد من المناطق وهذا
الاشتباك قادر يعني هذه المعارك ان تكون
داخل
الاحياء خاقد شباب وصافي التي شهدنا من
خلالها بالامس اشتباكات عن داخل الاحياء
ادت لعدد الاصابات وهنالك يعني انباع داخل
هذه استاذ عمار انا اكتفي معكم اشكرك
جزيلا عشان نعرض لكم هذه الصور والمشاهد
لقصف الطيران الحربي في الخرطوم حيث ما
زالت الاشتباكات مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
وكنا نشرنا لكم فيديو لانتشار قوات من
الجيش السوداني في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم حيث تتركز حده الاشتباكات في وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم وكما يؤكد ايضا شبكه
الصحفيين المتواجدين في الخرطوم وايضا
شبكه مراسله العربيه الان هذه هذا الفيديو
الذي نعرضه لكم هو مشاهد لقصف نفذته
مروحيات الجيش في الخرطوم اذا ما زال
الوضع على حاله ورغم اعلان هذه الهدنه
التي من المفترض ان تنتهي في غضون الساعات
المقبله ورغم ان الوضع يشهد هدنه ولكن حتى
هذه الساعه هناك خروقات عده وكما نتابع
هذا دخان الاسود الذي يتصاعد هناك انتشار
مكثف
والطيران الحربي من قبل مروحيات جيش
السوداني في وسط العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هذه المشاهد نعرضها لكم اول باول
وننقل لكم ايضا الصوره في ظل هذا الوضع
كله نتحدث عن حركه نزوح كبيره من العاصمه
السودانيه الى ولايات سودانيه اخرى وايضا
هناك الكثير ما زالوا عالقين وايضا ما
زالوا ينتظرون للخروج وسط الحدود عبر
الحدود الى بلدان المجاوره خصوصا افريقيه
منها نتحدث الى تشاد هرب كثير منهم الى
تشاد وفق المعلومات تتحدث عن عشرين الف
تقريبا وصلوا الى تشاد فيما ايضا ايضا
العديد من السودانيين المتواجدين على
الحدود لعبور مع مصر في ظل ايضا الحديث عن
عمليات اجلاء للرعايه من قبل الدول هذه
الصور ايضا ننقلها لكم
بمواجهات دخان مساله يتصاعد في اغلب
المناطق هذه هي الدبابه المنتشره وعلى ما
يبدو هناك بيوت احياء سكنيه بين الناس هذه
هي المواجهات على ما يبدو هناك تبادل بين
الطرفين فيما تتصاعد اعمده الدخان في سماء
هذه المنطقه وتغطي ايضا سماء المدينه فيما
بين البيوت هذه الدبابه تتواجد اذا بين
البيوت حيث كان هناك تنبيه وتحذير من الا
يتم اتخاذ المدنيين كدروع بشريه كان هناك
اتهامات لقوات الدعم السريع بانهم يتخذون
المدنيين كدروع بشريه فيما ايضا هناك
اتهامات للجيش بانهم يجرون هذه الاشتباكات
الى اماكن تواجد المدنيين اذا اتهامات لكل
طرفي النزاع المسلح العسكريين فيما يتعلق
بسلامه المدنيين حيث انهم يعيشون في حاله
رعب جراء ما يجري هناك تعرض عدد كبير من
منازل المدنيين والمواطنين للقصف ايضا
تضرر اسقف المنازل وهناك عدد كبير من
المواطنين يشكون ايضا من تعرضهم للسلب
والنهب يعني كان هناك ايضا اتهامات
لقوات الدعم السريع بانهم بانهم ايضا
يتعرضون للمدنيين في مقوات الدعم نفت هذه
الاتهامات ووجهتها الى الطرف الاخر نتابع
معكم اذا لمتابعه الاوضاع الطبيه ينضم
الينا من لندن الدكتور حسام طه جعفر وهو
مؤسس منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل حقوق
الانسان دكتور حسام مرحبا بك معنا في سياق
هذه التغطيه المعلومات الاخيره حتى هذه
اللحظه لعدد القتلى ما هي
مرحبا بكم حسب اللجنه التمهيديه لاطباء
السودان
التقرير رقم عشره صدر صباح اليوم
عدد القتلى من الميدانيين
وصل 264
وطبعا اللجنه التنفيديه للاطباء السودان
بتحصر القتل المدنيين الذين يصلون الى
المستشفيات
خارج المستشفى
يصعب
الحصر واكيد الاعداد اكثر من كده كثير
والجرحى وصلوا لالف فقط لكي نوضح
للمشاهدين
264 قتيلا هم من وصلوا المستشفى فقط العدد
مرشح ان يكون اكبر من ذلك بكثير لم يصل
الى المستشفى
وعدد الج
رحى الديانه الجرحى اللي وصلوا للمستشفيات
الحاله المزريه في المستشفيات انه كانوا
70% من المستشفيات في مناطق النزاع خارج
عن الخدمه
ودي مشكله كبيره خالص
وفي الامس
حصل
تعرضت بعض المستشفيات عدد اربعه مستشفيات
في مدينه الاوبيض بالقس المباشر
لكي نوضح الامور اكثر يا دكتور حسام عندما
تتحدث بانه 72% من المستشفيات في السودان
هي خارج عن الخدمه هل هذا يشمل الوضع في
داخل المستشفى ام مثلا الطرق المؤديه
للمستشفى هي خطره لا يتمكن المدنيون من
الوصول اليها سيارات الاسعاف او ما شابه
هل لك ان توضح لنا الصوره اكثر طبعا طبعا
الحالتين صحيحه انه
يص والخروج من المستشفيات يصعب لا بعد
الحدود وفي نفس الوقت الكادر الطبي
الموجود في المستشفيات منهك لابعد الحدود
لانه فيهم بعض الاخوه
شغالين لمده خمسه ايام بصوره متواصله وما
قادرين يصلوا يعني لبيوتهم ولناس عندهم
يعني
اهالي
واخوان خارج المستشفى هم قالقين عليهم وهم
عايزين يوصلوهم في نفس الوقت يعني يعني
يعانون داخل المستشفيات من انقطاعات
الطيار الكهربائي
ويعني شح المواد الغذائيه والماء ويعني
الحاله في حاله مزريه خالص
وانا اعرف يعني شخصيا انه في بعض
المستشفيات
وفي جراح وكان موجود لحد الان لمده خمسه
يوم ما اتحرك من المستشفى
والمستشفى ام درمان
يعني مستشفى كبير جدا وعدد الجراحين فيهم
يعدوا بالاصابع يعني
المواطنين الجرحى الاصابات
من اصل
79 مستشفى في الخرطوم الشغالات منهم 22
مستشفى
يعني بعد المستشفيات يعني بس
تستقبل الحوادث
لازم لازم نفكر في
المرضى الذين يعانون من الامراض
المزمنهم امراض مزمنه اليوم من نوعيه
الاصابات هل يمكن الحديث عن اصابات حرجه
اصابات طفيفه كيف يمكن وصفه في كثير من
الاصابات الحرجه طبعا لطبيعه الصراع في
السودان حاله حرب
كثير من ما في تفصيل لحد الان
كميه الاصابات الحرجه حسب يعني وضعها
الصحي لكن يعني كثير من الاصابات اللي انا
ذكرتها
10500 تقريبا هي
يعني هي الف وخمسمائه
فيهم اكيد اصابات حرجه خالص
واذا بنتكلم عن اصابات خارجه والمستشفيات
يعني خارج عن الخدمه حتى المستشفيات
الشغاله يعني ما عندها
يعني العيال العنايه المكثفه ما تكون يعني
شغاله الفل
فدي اشكاليه كبيره جدا ويعني وضع ماساوي
يعني لا بعد الحدود طيب دكتور حسام هل في
تنسيق مثلا بينكم كاطباء من هو متواجد في
منطقه ما ان يشرف مثلا على عدد من
المصابين بدل اللجوء الى المستشفيات في
حاله كانت الاصابات ربما طفيفه
والله يعني الجميل في المقاطع انه اخواني
في السودان في السودان واعضاء اللجنه
التمهيديه وعطويتنا في منظمه اطباء
السودان اللي هم عندهم عضويات مشتركه مع
اللجنه التمهيديه
عندهم تنظيم دقيق في على الارض ونحن
موجودين معاهم في في تنظيم والتنسيق
وهم يعني شغالين
ينصقوا العمل
بصوره جيده
بالامكانيات المتاحه يعني
نعم نعم تفضلي الدكتور حسام اليوم هل في
اولويه بالنسبه للمصابين
الموجودين في المستشفى وخصوصا من من هم
موجودون اصلا هناك كيف يتم التعامل معهم
طبعا هو
طبي وعلمي
وزي ما يقول بالانجليزي
يحقق الاولويه بالنسبه للمصابين
فمن ناحيه مهنيه
[موسيقى]
الشغل ماشي تمام لكن
تحتاجها المستشفيات الان لمداوات الجرحى
اكثر المواد اهم حاجه هو وسيله الماء
والكهرباء عشان الناس تشتغل
والدواء
ده احتياجات كبيره وفي لسته بالاحت
الاحتياجات موجوده عند اللجنه التنفيديه
للاطباء السودان وهم جاهزين
احتياجاتهم وين ففي يعني يعني حصر
الاحتياجات وليست للاحتياجات موجوده حالما
يكون في اتصال من المنظمات العالميه انا
اكتفي معك واشكرك جزيل الشكر من لندن
دكتور حسام طه جعفر مؤسس منظمه اطباء
السودان من اجل حقوق الانسان
ازمه اخرى تشهدها السودان ازمه خبز بدات
تتفاقم حيث رصدت كاميرا العربيه احتشاد
الطوابير امام الافران
لم يتوقف الامر عند ذلك حيث تهدد ازمه
المياه حياه السودانيين بعدما شهدت البلاد
انقطاعا تاما للمياه الصالحه للشرب اثراء
استهداف المعارك لمحطات المياه في العاصمه
نتابع
متى ما يجتمع عليه هؤلاء انه كنز من ماء
بئر بعد طول عناء ازمه انقطاع المياه في
السودان تدفع هؤلاء الى الامر مياه عكره
باتت بفعل الحرب صالحه للشرب فلا خيار اخر
يخاطر مدنيون في سبيل البحث عن الماء تشهد
المنطقه هنا وسط الخرطوم معارك محتدمه لم
يترك الرصاص شيئا الا وعليه اثره
رجع رجع جنب البير وقع جنبك اخيرا يعود
بعضهم محملين بما لا يروي ولا يغني من عطش
اما على الضفه هنا نهر على سعته يلجاون
اليه يحتفظون بماء النهر حيله قد تعينهم
لايام بعد معارك سببت نقصا في المياه
الصالحه للشرب
من سبع صباحا بنكون في شوارع ما بنلقى قرد
المويه لحدي اذان الظهر شحوا المياه يضرب
العاصمه الخرطومه بعد معارك بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع استهدفت محطات
المياه
محطات يصعب الوصول لها واصلاحها لاستمرار
الصراع في محيطها
فيما طالبت منظمه الصحه بوقف فوري لاطلاق
النار خوفا من تداعيات انسانيه قد تكون
الاسوا في تاريخ السودان غيداء السالم
العربيه
التغطيه مستمره ولكن نذهب قليلا الى ابرز
الاخبار الدوليه الاخرى اعلنت وزيره
داخليه الالمانيه توصل الحكومه والنقابات
العماليه الى اتفاق بشان رواتب اكثر من
مليونين ونصف مليون موظف في القطاع العام
اوضحت الوزيره في بيان ان كل عامل سيتلقى
ما مجموعه 3000 يورو على شكل اقساط حتى
فبراير العام المقبل للمساعده في التعويض
عن التضخم
احتاج نائب وزير الخارجيه الصيني على
تصريحات رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه بشان تايوان
حيث ذكر نائب وزير الخارجيه الصيني لسفير
كوريا الجنوبيه ان تصريحات رئيس الكوريه
الجنوبي غير مقبوله على الاطلاق مضيفا ان
رئيس الكوري الجنوبي لم يشر الى مبدا صين
واحده لكنه ساوى بين قضيه تايوان وقضيه
شبه الجزيره الكوريه في اشاره منه الى
قضيه شبه الجزيره الكوريه وقضيه تايوان
تختلفان تماما في طبيعتهما
قال مسؤولون محليون ان ما لا يقل عن خمسه
صواريخ روسيه اصابت مدينه خاركيف في شرق
اوكرانيا والمناطق المحيطه بها حيث كتب
حاكم المنطقه على تطبيق تيليجرام ان
صاروخا اصاب منزلا في احدى القرى جنوب
المدينه بينما تسبب صاروخ اخر في اندلاع
حريق كبير في المدينه نفسها والحق بعض
الاضرار في مباني المبدنيه هذا وتطلق
روسيا منذ اشهر طائرات مسيره وصواريخ ضد
مجموعات متنوعه من الاهداف الاوكرانيه في
محاوله لتدمير البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
دعا مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزه بوريل في مقال القوات
البحريه للدول الاعضاء في التكتل الى
القيام بدوريات في مضيق تايوان وشدد بوريل
على ضروره ان تكون اوروبا حاضره بشده في
قضيه تايوان التي اعتبرها مهمه على الصعيد
الاقتصادي والتجاري والتكنولوجي حسب صحيفه
الفرنسيه ودعا بوريلا للقوات البحريه
الاوروبيه القيامه بدوريات في مضيق تايوان
للدلاله على حرص اوروبا على حريه الملاحه
في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اذا في السودان ايضا اعلنت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اجلاء رعاياها من
الخرطوم وتعليق نشاطها ونشاط سفاراتها قال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن ان
بلاده علقت بصفه مؤقته العمليات في
سفاراتها بالخرطوم بسبب تزايد المخاطر
الامنيه واجلت جميع الموظفين الامريكيين
وعائلاتهم بامان
قبل ذلك قال مسؤول بوزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الاداره الامريكيه لا تتوقع
تغيير الاوضاع الامنيه في السودان على
المدى القصير واشار الى ان واشنطن على
اتصال وثيق بالجيش السوداني والقاده
المدنيين لمحاوله تمديد وقف اطلاق النار
اضحى مسؤول في بانتاجون ان حوالي 100 جندي
شاركوا في اجراء الموظفين الامريكيين من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
يبدو ان واشنطن تضع سيناريوهات في حال
تصاعد التوترات في السودان لمرحله اللا
عوده حيث تتجه لتعزيز قدرتها العسكريه في
المنطقه فاين يتمركز الجيش الامريكي في
افريقيا نتابع
معسكر
رسميا هو القاعده العسكريه الدائمه
والوحيده التي تديرها القوات الامريكيه في
افريقيا
جغرافيا هي اقرب قاعده امريكيه في المنطقه
للاحداث في السودان وهي تقع في دوله
جيبوتي
القاعده تضم وحدات من القوات الخاصه
والبحريه والطيران ويصل عدد القوات فيها
الى 4000 جندي في الاوقات العاديه تستغل
لحمايه الملاحه البحريه في باب المندب وفي
استهداف الجماعات الارهابيه في القرن
الافريقي اضافه الى تدريب الجنود التابعين
لدول افريقيه مختلفه
معسكر
يحتوي على مطار عسكري قد يكون هو المحور
الاساسيه في اي عمليه اخلاء محتمله
للسفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم
انس نماسي العربيه
التغطيه مستمره على شاشه العربيه
وننقله بالصوت والصوره للفيديوهات التي
تردنا مع شبكه مراسلي العربيه والضيوف
الكرام التغطيه مستمره الى زميلنا في
الاحمر الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات